[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba Tekrar
dünyada bir tek şeyin karşılığında ödül
olarak hem para hem saygı alırsınız bu
şey insiyatiftir Peki siyatif nedir
doğru şeyi söylenmeden yapmaktır
insiyatif 10 yıl önce bugün son hamile
günümdü 10 yılda aldığım en cesurca
kararlarımın beni buraya getirdiğine
eminim
hayatındaki en büyük tutkumu ve
mükemmeliyetçiliğime annemin birinci yaş
günü itibariyle hazırladığı o Şaheser
davet masalarının boşta olduğuma da
eminim
şöyle bir masa düşünün inanılmaz sade
kat izi olmayacak kadar ütülü kendinden
desenli kesinlikle renkli değil
krem renklerinde bir örtü
çorba kasesinden başlayarak aşağıya
doğru 5 tane tabak
peçete ve bardağı hiç anlatmıyorum son
olarak Çatalca bıçak konusu çoktan
açılmış durumda
önünüzde Duran tatlı servislerinin hemen
bir yenisi tekrar verilmek üzere yan
tarafta Gümüş yine örtülü bir tepside
duruyor Neden mi Çünkü benim annemin
asla bir tatlısı yoktur Her zaman bir
tatlı menüsü vardır
o menüde çeşit çeşit tereyağlı
kurabiyeler vardır ve o kurabiyeleri Siz
yine kendisinin hazırladığı 3 çeşit
marmelatla yiyebilin diye üstleri hafif
çöküktür size elinize bir kurabiye alıp
sadece ısırmak istediğinizde bambaşka
bir deneyim yaşarsınız ve her ısırıkta
farklı bir marmelatla yemek istersiniz O
hiç üşenmeden açtığı tereyağlı sable
hamurları kakaolu ve vanilyalı daha
başrole yaklaşmadım bile mevsimine göre
tercih ettiği Çilek diş şeftali yaptığı
muhallebileri Benim de yaptığım
televizyon programında en çok dikkat
çeken en çok izlenilen ve yapılan tarif
olan o hiçbir yerde yiyemeyeceğiniz sade
anne keki Evet başrole geldim İki günde
yapılabilen ve o ünlü Şefin dediği gibi
bir pasta yaptım yanağını Dayar uyursun
Aynen böyle bir pasta
gerçek çikolata kullanılarak yapılan
ganajın pürüzsüz bir ganaj o ganajın
servis sırasında üzerine döküldüğü pasta
rokoko genelde başrolü kimseye vermez
çocukluğum ve
gençliğimi neredeyse tamamını annesinin
yanında mutfakta getirmiş biri olarak
tabii ki hayalim
annemle birlikte minik bir pasta ve
çikolata Dükkanı açmaktı Ama bunlar
Hayallerim gerçekler ise üniversite ÖSS
falan
Akademik olarak hep çalışkan bir öğrenci
olduğum için mesleki tercihimin de en
iddialı bölüm olması gerekiyordu Tamam
dedim karar verdim ben Tıp tercih
edeceğim kabul edelim birçoğumuz
üniversite tercihlerinde çok da bilinçli
değiliz
hayallerimizle üniversite tercihlerimiz
ne kadar birbiriyle ilişkili kaç kişi
dikkat ediyor Bilmiyorum ben Dikkat
etmemişim bakın hikayeme Ankara'daki tıp
fakültelerine puanı yetmeyince Yan
komşumuzun mühendis olması ona
danışmanla şekillenmiş kariyerimden bir
şey anlatmak istiyorum En iyilerden
oluşan Dershane sınıfında bir
arkadaşımın elektrik elektronik
mühendisliği ilk tercih seçeceğini
duyduğumda Yahu bir kızı için hiç uygun
Meslek mi diye herkesin içinde söylemiş
5 yılın sonunda; onun Diş Hekimi benim
elektrik elektronik mühendisi olduğum
bir üniversite geçmişim var hayatın
değişik bir mizah anlayışı var bana
karşı
hem de onur öğrencisi olacak kadar
sahiplendiğim Mesleğimi Türkiye'nin en
iyi en büyük üretim fabrikalarından
birinde savunma sanayi üretim mühendisi
olarak ilk iş deneyime başladım
ben hiç üretim yapılan bir fabrika
görmemişim arkadaşlar Hem de nasıl bir
fabrika fabrikayı gezdirdiğim herkesin
ağzını açık bırakan Türkiye'nin de
yaşamıma Sanayi firmalarında çalışan
arkadaşlarımın Yahu en iyi mühendisliği
siz yapıyorsunuz burası nasıl bir yer
dediği bir yerde
tutulmuştum üretime
her gün yüzlerce insan aynı anda o
fabrikaya giriyor üstlerini
değiştiriyorlar binlerce ürün
üretiyorlar hem de son teknoloji
makinaları hiç durmuyor benim için bu
izlediklerim adeta kusursuz yönetilen
bir orkestraydı
ne ürettiğim lamb bağımsız üretme
çoğaltma ve yenilik fikrine gerçekten
tutulmuştum
ikinci ayı geçmedim Burada da aldığım
insiyatifler
yöneticinin bana şunu dediğini
hatırlıyorum Elif çok insiyatif
alıyorsun insan kaynakları direktörümün
de bana ya Bu köyün delisi sen misin
dediğini hatırlıyorum
şimdilerde ise ben ekip arkadaşlarıma
sürekli şunu söylüyorum çok insiyatif
alın Çünkü istediğiniz şeyi ulaşmanın
tek yolu budur insiyatif alabilen
insanlar dünyalarını değiştirirler
yine çok yoğun çalıştığım dönemlerden
birinde kendimi çok şanslı hissettim
Çünkü hayatımın daha başında ne yapmak
istediğimi karar vermiştim bulmuştum
ve bir karar daha verdim ailem ikna
edecek bir fizibiliti hazırladım aile
Meclisine sundum Bu benim için çok büyük
bir şeyin başlangıcıydı Hani o ilk kadın
var ya en zor adımdır atması ben o Adımı
attım Cesur olun
Atın o ilk adımı buna değecek güvenin
bana
ama bir mühendisin fizibilitesi bu kadar
farklı olabilirdi bu kadar Evdeki hesap
çarşıya uymamıştı yine de kararımı hiç
değiştirmedim hiç Ümitsizliğe kapılmadım
Bence insan karakterinin en önemli
özelliği değişmez kararlılığıdır hiç
değiştirmedim kararımı ve O dükkanı
açtım ama ne kadar kolay söylüyorum 5
harften oluşan bir kelime açmak neler
oldu neler yaşandı ne zorluklar yine de
aldığım bütün insiyatifler beni yoluma
çıkardı Peki neler oldu o dükkanda bir
süre içeriye giren insanların simit
sormasıyla sınandım yağmur yağsa içeriye
giren insan olmamalı
reklamsız marka yaratılara en büyük
örnek olan kulaktan kulağa bilinir olan
dükkanımda bir pazar safı çok tatlı bir
çiftin içeriye girdiği şöyle dediğini
hatırlıyorum girerek Yahu buradaki bu
kalabalık neden ne satıyorsunuz bu
arabalar neden bu kuyruk neden
pazar kahvaltılarımızın 3 hafta önceden
doğduğunu
rezervasyonların yetişmediğini
hatırlıyorum ha bir şey daha
hatırlıyorum Cuma günü Şef önümü giyerek
girdiğim pastane mutfağından pazar günü
Annem geldiğinde aldığım nefesi
Cumartesi sabah dükkanı süpürmeye gelen
Biricik Personelimizin ilk açılışa gelen
uyuduğum chesterdan ya beni
uyandırdığını ya da üzerime örttüğünü
gün geçiyor Benim hayallerim her gün
ilerliyordu arkadaşlar dükkanda sonuç
olarak
pastacılık sektörüne bile yaptığım
dönemde
inovasyonlarımla yeni bir soluk getirmiş
pastanelerimi para kazanır hale
getirmiştim ama dediğim gibi Gün
geçtikçe bütün hayallerim büyüyordu
bir kitap okumuştum Tam da o dönemde
kitapta yazar diyordu ki
yazar Bir patron bir patronun itirafları
şirketimi nasıl batırdım isimli yazar bu
kitabında tüp tüccarlarının çalışma
prensiplerini çarıktan çarığa olarak
nitelendiriyordu bana ilk olarak çok
abartılı bir laf gelmişti çarıktan çarı
Yani şunu demek istiyordu Baba çarık
Giyer oğlu iskarpin Torun yine çarık
giyermiş
ticarethaneler üçüncü nesle gitmeden
kapanır gidermiş
düşününce bir süre sonra anlamlı geldi
gerçekten ben bir karar daha verdim
değil üçüncü nesle 13 nesle kadar devam
edecek dünyanın her yerini o tutkuyla
ürettiğim ürünleri satabilecek Global
bir marka yapacaktım
bununla da birlikte en başta ekonomik ve
benim için en önemlisi sosyolojik olarak
bulunduğum topluma çok fayda sağlayacak
nesiller süre nesiller boyunca yarar
sağlayacaktım Gerçekten bu benim için
Hayallerim ve gerçeklerim arasında çok
büyük bir savaştı Hani diyorlar ya Savaş
sanatı üzerine düşünülmeyip hesap
yapılmadıkça kazanılması imkansız bir
bilimdir gerçekten öyle yaptım üzerine
düşünmek için yanıma aldığım bana yol
göstereceğine emin olduğum bir kaç
kitapla birlikte seyahate çıktım bu
seyahatin ana teması düşünmek sadece
düşünmek dinlenmek falan değil hatta
sadece kitap okumak bile değil o kitabın
yazarıyla sohbet etmek fikir
alışverişinde bulunmak
bol bol düşünün her şeyi bırakın Dursun
bolca düşünün en çok düşünmeye vakit
ayırın
O Zaman hızla siz bile inanamayacaksınız
düşünmekten kaçınan insanların
yapamayacağı hiçbir şey yoktur o
Aynısının tıpkısı ürünleri kopyalayan
insanlar gibi aynı yapmayın her zaman
farklı hedefleyin her zaman farklıyı
görün bir anda olabilmek için her zaman
fikir üretimine zaman ayırın fikir
üretimine yatırım yapın ben de bu
Düşünmek için çıktığım seyahatimde bana
çok yakın çok güvendiğim birini dediği
bir şeyi hatırladım Bana dedi ki Elif ya
hiç Yapma ya zamanla hiç harcama
Arkadaşlar ben bu düşünce Tatilimin
sonunda o Magic şeyi bulmuştum
Medet şey Ve hayatımdaki o Tutkun olduğu
medikçe Aslında Tutkun olduğum o içimi
şenlendiren şeyi bulmuştum o ve o ürün
ve benim hayatımdaki o yürütme üretme
tutkundan doyan heyecanım bana İhtiyacım
olan yatırımı getirdi hem de yatırımcıma
yaptım 15 dakikalık iş teklifi sunumunda
Bence hayatındaki en önemli sunumdu
Peki yatırım kararını belirleyen tek şey
Tutku mudur Elbette hayır
son şey midir son kararda etkili midir
Kesinlikle evet yatırımcılar yapılan bir
araştırmaya göre girişimcilerin
potansiyellerini 13 ana kriterde
inceliyor birincisi fikrin gücü ikincisi
girişimin gücü üçüncüsü ise hissedilen
Tutku
girişimcinin yaşından eğitiminden
şirketin kurulmuş amacından her şeyinden
daha önemli hissedilen Tutku Özellikle
de benim gibi öz sermaye yatırımı yapan
insanlar için bu çok önemli
şu an milyon dolarlık fikirler
üretebilen 500'den fazla çalışanı olan
gururla söylüyorum yüzde yetmiş kadın
çalışanı olan olan şirketimin ceo'suyum
bir Ceo iyi bir Ceo olmalıdır arkadaşlar
yani inovasyon kurulu başkanıdır
inovasyon bir yöneticiyi bir liderden
ayıran en önemli şeydir inovasyonlar
gelene kadar para ayırdığınızda hiç
bilgisi yok
Biz ürünlerimizi piyasaya sunduğumuzda
benzer işi yapan insanlar eminim Arge
bizden 100 kat para harcıyorlardı
olayın parayla hiç bilgisi yok Olay
tamamen kimlerle çalıştığınızda onları
nasıl yönettiğinizde ve işten ne kadar
anladığınızda saklı
dünyada en iyi ürünü üretmeye Tutkun
İnsanları işe aldım yetenek öyle
özgeçmişten anlaşılabilen bir şey değil
yeteneğin altyapısında temelinde
inanççılık ciddiyet dayanıklılık
kararlılık ve iş adamışlık var
arkadaşlar ve Bu ekiple birlikte sadece
dedik ki paranın satın alabileceği en
iyi çikolatayı yapalım biz o ürünü
yaptık
yetinmedik çok bağlı kalmadık o ürüne en
az o ürün kadar yeni ve inovatif birçok
ürün yaptık Şu an 12 ana kategoride 400
ürünümüz var bir şeyin inovatif olması
için onun yeni şaşırtıcı kökünden
kullanışlı olması gerekir yeni bir
beyinde insanda dopamin salgılatır
dopamin beynin kaydet tuşudur
ve eğer yani sadece bir üründe dopamin
varsa eğer o ürün akılda kalır Bunu hiç
unutmayın
işim
in Daha doğrusu tutkularımı işime
dönüştürmek yıllarımı aldı işimiz
hayatlarımızın en büyük bölümünü
dolduruyor
Eğer gerçekten mutlu olmak istiyorsanız
gerçekten Tutkun olduğunuz şey yapmanız
gerekiyor çünkü bu iş o kadar zor ki
eğer tutkuyla bağlı değilseniz aklı
Selin birisi hemen pes eder
hala tutkularınızı bulmadıysanız onu
arayın
bulduğunuzda kalbin her meselesinde
olduğu gibi
hissedeceksiniz yetinmeyin Aramaya devam
edin
büyük hamleler hiçbir zaman ucuz
değildir
zamanımız sınırlı
tutkunuzu bulun
cesaretinizi toplayın ve alın O
insiyatifi bir şey daha var Lütfen
işinizi şansa bırakmayın şans sadece
yetişmiş kafalara yardım eder teşekkür
ederim